Let's look at different equation then. One like this one. Y equals X squared
plus 6x plus three. Now we can't factor this. Know that the only factors of 3
are 3 and 1, and they don't add to equal 6. So we're going to need to come up
with a different way, a different method, of figuring out where this curve
touches the x axis. I'd like you to write this Right side of the equation in
completed square form. So, in other words, complete the square on the right
side. However, this time, don't move the 3 over to the left-hand side. Keep it
on the right side and just play with the first two terms here to complete the
square. Once you've completed the square with these two, tack the 3 on to the
end again and simplify. Fill the new expression you have on the right-hand side
into this box.